[Musique]
on constate par exemple aujourd'hui que
le chômage partiel continue d'augmenter
de plus en plus d'entreprises y ont
recours est donc il faut mécaniquement
qu'on augmente l'enveloppent qui est qui
est affairé à ce chômage partiel c'est
pour que les talents restent au sein des
entreprises et que quand l'activité
économique redémarre on puisse avoir un
maximum d'entreprises qui repartent avec
leurs salariés qui sont formés et qu'il
n'y ait pas une vague de chômage et une
déperdition des compétences on a aussi
un enjeu de formation un enjeu
d'innovation qui nous permettra de
rester acteur sur la scène
internationale est je pense un enjeu de
coordination très fort au niveau
européen
dans cette soirée un petit peu en
matière économique les actions qu'on
pourrait dessiner mais il serait trop
tôt pour affirmer encore exactement
quelle forme ça m'apprend